all right we're gonna kick off today's
show with a fun outdoor activity that's
perfect for the holiday season
yes jc is taking us ice skating at the
cosmopolitan ice skating rink let's
check it out
it is whoa it is so good to be back in
the ice rink here at the cosmopolitan
and with my buddy fedor good to see you
again good to see you again jc
so you have some new hours happening
right now what are the new hours we
haven't yeah right now in the holiday
times it's expanded hours we're open
from 12 noon every day to 11. which is
perfect for families uh watching right
now the kids maybe they don't have at
home schooling right now during this
christmas great thing come down
and do some ice skating let's talk about
some of the features here because you
can ice skate like we're doing right now
but you also have fire pits what else we
have going on well we've got a whole
bunch of
stuff for people to do besides skate
we've got fire pits you can
you can sit down and watch the view
we've got a full menu available
we've got holiday cocktails don't fall
oh yeah
so i mean it's it's really a great
environment for people to have a good
time and and celebrate with their
families
we had some friends that came down here
for for your date night in a movie so we
still doing where you can come down here
and skate with your family or your date
and
and watch a movie we have holiday movies
they go all the way to the third
every monday and tuesday starting at 6
30 p.m now lance get a shot of the ice
fix i think this is so adorable this
this this kid right here and they've got
what do we call this triceps are like
training
well this is like a skate aid it's the
seal we also have another one that looks
like a rudolph the
red-nosed reindeer and basically if you
want it you can use it to help you skate
that one allows people to sit and be
pushed as well we have we offer helmets
for people that want them free of charge
so come down and take advantage while
the rake is still here and you also have
all kinds of safety when it comes to the
covert precautions there's only x amount
of people allowed on the ice rink
and social distancing is in play as well
correct
it's such a great time the ice rink at
the cosmopolitan you want to race back
to the camera i beat you last time
remember that let's try it again here we
go
we sent it back to the studio the race
is on
he always lets me win we'll send it back
to you guys in the studio
that boy knows how to have fun huh how
is he not on the golden knights with
that kind of skating right exactly
exactly
i